I literally can't even believe that I
get to be here with my sisters my
stepsisters
Melanie lynskey and Megan dogs
Drew Barrymore returning to her fairy
tale roots
just breathe the actress reunited with
her ever after co-stars Melanie lynskey
and Megan Dodds who played her
stepsisters in the 1998 film what did I
do think Daniel think really hard
we're just here in a time machine and
we're back 25 years ago because it's the
25th anniversary of Ever After the olden
days were very much more romantic yeah
25 years later the ladies are
celebrating the classic retelling of
Cinderella costumes and all I literally
can't even believe that I get to be here
with my sisters as great as this not
your normal average every day occurrence
here the prince went to the king and
asked him to release all those men he
didn't and seems the cats bonded on set
last year Melanie told E.T all the
behind the scenes details oh gosh it's
just such a supportive environment it
was a really wonderful time like
Angelica would have these dinner parties
and we'd all go over there and have so
much French wine and sing and Drew would
be like a little dj playing her CDs she
and I would go everywhere with like
those Case Logic remember those from the
90s we would both have those and be like
putting music on and just these epic
dinner parties in the south of France
and I was like movie making is Magic and
they're not all like that I came to
learn they're not also magic but it was
a good time
forgive me oh highness I did not see you
your aim would suggest otherwise even
though it is a fairy tale there's a lot
of Truth in it
um which I find really wonderful because
I think that when you've told a story a
certain amount of times a certain way
it's it's very amazing to be able to go
to it and find new things in it and have
it also trick you I mean this story
takes you in places where you certainly
don't expect and the outcome you don't
really know what it's going to be and I
think that's amazing because I think
people feel like they know this story so
well that um to have it be different is
um is a really nice change of pace
earlier this month Melanie recalled
another memory with her on-screen sis on
The Tonight Show which is just like the
most special the kindest person I I had
this moment she gave me a gift when we
started doing Ever After and it was so
sweet and I was like I want to get her a
gift and I found that this Antique
Market these plates and I gave them to
her and she was like oh my God
each one of these plates was to fall to
the floor and smash into a thousand
million pieces
each one of the pieces would scream I
love you Melanie but the impression she
says wasn't planned we had been
backstage talking about how sweet she
was I'm not like generally impersonating
people I think sometimes when I tell a
story about someone their voice comes
out of my body and it happened on
television
while Ever After has gone on to become a
fan favorite Drew recently opened up to
ET about how it's impacted her to this
day when I was in my early 20s and did
ever after I was like it I don't think I
would be the same person without being
given a spin on what we think a princess
is supposed to be I was trying to start
a company and wanted to tell stories and
make films and that particular messaging
that you could rescue yourself that you
didn't have to wait to be rescued is
definitely the thing that set me up best
in my life and I don't know who I would
be honestly without it it changed the
way I saw the world
foreign